in an occasion that again puts together
the work of the European Commission and
the council and in these circumstances
is to highlight the work that the
European Union together thus in the
neighborhood so many pictures of faces
have been gathered together I know this
is a selection there are much more that
you can find on the internet but this
one's in a very few pictures you really
have affirmative particularly
interesting a very very well done policy
the policy who which which unites where
is where there is talk of division that
opens when it seems safer too close and
help find the common solution where is
fashionable or just easier
about solidarity and about finding modus
vivendi in a mutually beneficial way
sometimes however neighborhoods can be
rough some say it failed to deliver
enough what others think it has gone too
far given the dramatic developments in
the region particularly and and the
first one is of course I welcome you all
to this event and thank you particularly
our partners and friends from the union
for the Mediterranean from the partner
countries from the Eastern Partnership
partner countries and I would very much
like to thank also the very close
cooperation with the council colleagues
and the attendant presidency a man that
had been a great support to the
partnership with the South American
countries and to the UFM in particular
you